hier ist die erste im auto ich hab's
geschafft politik habe ich besonders zu
tun die merkel können uns mal was geld
[Musik]
lange genug hat der ausländer auf
deutschen autobahnen für lau herum
schmarotzer und deswegen wird jetzt
abkassiert sind gerade einem
österreichischen auto entstiegen dem
entnehme ich dass die österreicher sind
es ist soweit die außenhaut die
ausländer maut ist da wir haben die
faxen dicke es wird jetzt endlich die
maut verlangt von den ausländern gericht
ich sage gleiches mit gleichem vergelten
[Musik]
auge zahn um zahn ja nicht selber aber
manchmal ironisch das land hier ja ich
habe übrigens ich finde es noch
wirkungsvoller was sie sagen wenn sie in
der stimme von erich honecker gesprochen
wird
irgendwann in deutschland gebaut hat
oder ich ja und warum also mit wir haben
auch gefallen es war ein österreicher
die autobahn gebaut wird deutschland
deswegen müssten mehr gratis ist war
dabei momente nicht geplant es ist das
ist jetzt pflicht weil ich sage es ist
nicht bloß wieder seehofer sagt die maut
kommt sage ich jetzt ist es pflicht
das könnte man vergessen sind die
politik statt regen ein so 250 kilometer
gefahren da gibt es einen pick also
sagen wir mal der österreicher was wollt
ihr immer von uns haben
johann hätte glaube da findet ein
bisschen teiliger glaube ja natürlich
haben es genauso und einer für die 150
euro bekommen gerade mit dem nötigsten
wie man an meinem dienstwagen sieht
zurande
und jetzt muss einfach der ausländer
auch mal zahlen für die autobahn so sie
mir ihre armut
aber ich bin halt gefunden dort war aber
was das sind sie kommen aus hamburg und
erlauben sich dann solche flüssigkeiten
seid ihr für das vollkommen offen mit
ein bisschen was sie zahlen ab nächstem
jahr auch mode sofern ich schon mal klar
schön da noch
wie seehofer mao mit einem stattlichen
münchen geht es nun zum könig aus und
seinen getreuen hofschranzen hallöchen
die kohle ist das erste mal geld ist da
gab's eingesammelt es ist so schön
ja und das mit der merkel und mit der eu
die können uns einfach mal oder da
warten wir ja dass wir schon sehen war
vor allem wohin sie uns können kein
ministerpräsident jetzt die erste maut
kohle
ich hab's geschafft politik habe ich
auch besonders zu tun die merkel kann
uns mal was damals in die eu
ebenso tja wenn er seehofer meine kohle
nicht haben will dann verkaufe ich seit
verwiesen
michael b schreibt auf facebook wilke du
bist der letzte arsch nur große fresse
ich möchte ich mal sehen wenn es hart
auf hart kommt dann schaust du dir in
die hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt
man trifft sich immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zwei oder hier auf
youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren